Facebook's Sheryl Sandberg admits the
company did not strengthen its security
fast enough to safeguard the data of up
to 87 million users affected by its
privacy scandal Sandberg Facebook's
chief operating officer is now
apologizing for that failure she said
yesterday quote we were way too
idealistic and a Warner is here now with
what Facebook promises to do to regain
the trust of more than 2 billion users
and a good morning seems like a big job
yeah good morning Gail Sandberg says
that Facebook plans to double the
security operations department from
10,000 employees to 20,000 by the end of
the year on Monday Facebook also intends
to notify the millions of users who may
have been impacted by the Cambridge
analytical leak we know that we did not
do a good enough job protecting people's
data and I'm really sorry for that and
marks really sorry for that in an
interview with Bloomberg Facebook CEO Oh
Sheryl Sandberg focused on the company's
future after the massive data breach
what people want to know from us is are
we gonna take steps to be more
protective and more proactive and the
answer to that is affirm yes on Monday
Facebook says it will make it clearer
for users to see which apps they're
connected to and how to delete them
founder Mark Zuckerberg says in 2013 an
app called this is your digital life
began harvesting data of the roughly
300,000 Facebook users who downloaded
the app and their friends the collected
data he says was eventually shared with
political consulting firm Cambridge
analytic a violating Facebook's privacy
terms Cambridge analytic I hadn't ID
wrongdoing this week Facebook said data
from as many as 87 million users may
have been scraped I'm not gonna sit here
and say we won't find more problems we
will and this is a forever thing because
security is an arms race Sandberg also
pushed back against X Facebook employees
who've criticized the company's
practices saying it's obviously
disappointing when people who worked
here speak out we have an incredibly
open culture internally last year former
Facebook executive Seamus Polly Hypatia
said he felt tremendous guilt building
the social media giant it literally is a
point now where I think we have created
too
that are ripping apart the social fabric
of how society works
Sandberg says that a few of Facebook's
advertisers have paused their spending
following the Cambridge analytical
scandal Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is
scheduled to testify before Congress
about the data leak beginning on Tuesday
guessing some people have some questions
for him yeah and it sounds like Samberg
didn't answer them all right
hopefully they'll hear more next week
thank you Anna